so Puerto Rico is part of the United
States that that's not gonna be breaking
news to a lot of people in our audience
but there are lots of people who seem
not to know that or maybe they know it
but they refuse to accept it because
they don't want to and in Illinois a
woman named Mia Irizarry was it the
forest preserves of Cook County and this
is the type of place where you can get a
permit to have a cookout and you can
grill your dogs you're all beef kosher
dogs or your vegan dog or your dog or
whatever whatever right and it was Mia
eras eras birthday she was wearing a
t-shirt that said Puerto Rico and had
the Puerto Rican flag on it and a man
came up to her a I guess we would say a
white American male that's the the the
designation I've found for this
individual very aggressively and started
badgering her for wearing the shirt and
calling the shirt on American which is
so funny because what countries porto
rico part of again all right it's part
of the united states how is it on
american to wear a shirt that says
puerto rico and i have some of the video
for you and there's an interesting
second layer to the story which is that
while the harassment was going on there
was another seemingly white male police
officer right there and refused to do
anything about it and that officer on
the basis of this video has now been
assigned to desk duty pending an
investigation into why didn't he do
anything when this man was harassing the
woman and the woman was asking for help
let's check out like a minute and a half
of the video it's more than a half hour
long in total let's look at about 90
seconds well first of all the United
States owns Puerto Rico so we're part of
the United States
are you at
why does okay okay well what's your
point sir because I can officer can you
climb renting this area and he's
harassing me about the shirt that I'm
wearing I did rent it I have a permit
for this right so can you please step
away from me sir can you please step
away from me I'm not trying to change
anyone I'm just trying to come here for
a birthday party okay yes I am can you
please get away from me can you please
get away from me
officer officer
I feel highly uncomfortable can you grab
please officer
yeah okay that gives us a sense of
what's going on so isn't it on American
for Americans to tell other Americans
that they're an American or that they're
not Americans or to question their
American citizenship and eventually a
female officer arrived and actually
dealt with the guy identified him as
being drunk and threatened to arrest him
for harassment if he didn't go away and
I mean this entire thing about
questioning whether Puerto Ricans are
American that's actually not new I'm
more concerned from this story with the
officers unwillingness to get involved a
xenophobic guy gets drunk his
inhibitions are decreased and he says
the xenophobic things that he's always
thinking fine but why does the officer
do nothing as this man is physically
intimidating and verbally harassing this
woman and I'm hoping that the
investigation gives us answers because
that's actually what's most unusual
about this I'm horrified by the fact
that this woman was was harassed in this
way and by the stupidity of this man but
what was up with the officer in this
entire thing yeah and I guess the
punishment for the officer for doing
nothing is to essentially do nothing
right his desk to desk duty yeah
Puerto Rico's part of the United States
it's not a state it's a Commonwealth
Puerto Ricans have been American
citizens since 1917 there's no other
country that Puerto Ricans might be part
of which makes it extra weird when the
guy says you shouldn't be wearing that
shirt in this country like what's the
right country to wear a Puerto Rico
shirt in is it Ghana
I don't think so is it Belgium I don't
think so I think it's the United States
Puerto Ricans vote in American
presidential primaries Puerto Ricans the
Puerto rican-american thing is a
surprisingly elusive fact and there's a
USA Today poll from a few months ago we
covered it around the Hurricanes we're
only like 47% of Americans believed that
Puerto Ricans are citizens by birth some
believe that they are citizens but only
like if they apply for citizenship which
of course isn't true and some other
subset just believe that Puerto Ricans
aren't citizens of the u.s. at all and
of course they are citizens by birth and
as far as this guy goes I don't excuse
what the guy did at all I genuinely want
to know how people become like this guy
but I wonder is this what you do if your
life is just not going well
like you started to say that Puerto
Ricans are on American I think he's
drunk and rambling and surprise surprise
he was wrong about quite a few things
like yeah he suggested that she wear an
American flag shirt that's against the
flag code buddy you can't be doing that
either but you're not excusing the
behavior as being only because of the
drinking right oh I don't know I don't
know if you would have gone out and done
this exact wasn't drunk but yes clearly
what he thinks on the inside and the
owner has brought that out
these are his beliefs and he was
arguably disinhibited by the drinking
and the entire unamerican thing by the
way it's a red scare tactic dating back
to the McCarthy era and the HUAC it's
basically ignorant nationalism used to
draw a line between us and them and
we'll follow up and see what ultimately
happens to the officer involved